Donald Trump will be the new President of the United States
The U.S. tycoon and former president completely the Iowa caucus,
With this election it is defined that he will be the
representative of the Republican Party in the next election,
with a victory of more than 30 points difference,
with second place Ron de Santis,
current governor of Florida,
In third place was Nicky Hayley,
the former U.S. ambassador to the UN.
Trump won to the unity of the party and assured that "whatever
needs to be done" and reaffirmed his desire to seal the southern border.
The American media,
while not surprised by the victory,
have shown their dissatisfaction with
Trump's approach to returning to the White House.
Among his campaign promises we find his
opposition to the gender transition of minors,
reducing crime and putting the United States first.
Joe Biden,
the current president,
commented on this fact on his social networks and
stated that Trump is the clear favorite on the other side.
At this time Biden did not hesitate to call Trump extremist MAGA voters
the slogan Make America Great Again and they will have to face them And
you what do you think of Donald Trump's victory I read you in the comments.